la atención aumenta en Taiwán buques de
combate chinos fueron desplegados en las
aguas que rodean la isla Beijing
prometió una respuesta firme por el
encuentro este miércoles entre la
presidenta taiwanesa zaynhuen y el
presidente de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos Kevin
mccarthy pero no detuvo la visita de una
delegación estadounidense este jueves a
Taiwán con el objetivo de reafirmar su
reconocimiento de la soberanía de taipei
y de China de invadir La Isla
nos reuniremos con la presidenta y
hablaremos de los sistemas de armamento
que aprobaré y que se enviarán a Taiwán
para fortalecer el país están preparados
los taiwaneses tenemos suficiente
disuasión para detener la agresión de la
china comunista
pero los taiwaneses temen un posible
conflicto armado en su isla
no queremos la guerra y tenemos que
resolver este problema pacíficamente es
lo mejor para nosotros la gente
corriente no creo que los políticos se
van a dejarse influir por Estados Unidos
utilizándonos como Carne de cañón
por otro lado otros ven necesario
defender su libertad
los chinos han hecho a menudo
comentarios que amenazan y construyen a
Taiwán internacionalmente y también
construyen al pueblo taiwanés
las acciones de la presid han enviado el
mensaje de que el pueblo taiwanés no
teme las amenazas chinas de usar la
fuerza contra nosotros
de un partido que lucha por la
independencia de taipei mientras que
china considera que la isla Autónoma es
una de las provincias que debe
reconquistar al nombre de su principio
de la china única por el momento la
respuesta China no se puede comparar a
las maniobras militares que habían
seguido la visita a la isla de la
demócrata Nancy pelosi el año pasado
Pero igualmente ponen alerta a Taiwán